Jeremy we're here to talk about your
latest film now is good and it's a movie
that's really filled with tears but also
laughter isn't it tell me a little bit
more about it yeah I mean I mean it's
it's I guess quite an intense subject
matter but I mean I chose this movie
because of because of how funny it was
you know it had the it's kind of 80%
humor and I think I think that's you
know you have to earn those intense
moments you know you can't expect an
audience just just to feel that sort of
emotional connection without giving them
the right amount of contrast and that's
what this movie does so well and it's
kind of like a girl getting a the best
excuse in the world to do whatever she
wants you know she goes out and she she
all that inner turmoil comes out as
rebelling and she goes and takes drugs
and does all the things that parents one
doesn't you know wouldn't want to do and
gets in a lot of trouble and that's
where they that's where the humor comes
from you know yeah now you mentioned
that of course Dakota Fanning because
she plays the young girl who has
leukemia terminal leukemia and she's
kind of trying to pack everything in
isn't it before her last days and she
gets a kind of license to do whatever
she wants in a way or she gives herself
that what would you do if you could just
do absolutely anything you want to do
you know I'd have all the roles that I
want to have no I I don't know I don't
know I mean um as an actor you always
being you were very mollycoddled when
you're working on sets at the amount you
know any sort of other thing that could
possibly be dangerous not allowed to do
so I mean I was just in Texas doing a
doing a movie and I went on while
there's mechanical bulls and I the
trouble I got it over that was insane so
I do all the stuff that you're not
allowed to when you're working I guess
yeah all dangerous stuff and what was it
like working with Dakota Fanning it goes
great you know she's um she's done more
movies than the most actors have at the
end of their career and she's she's 17
so um you know it's not often you get to
work with someone so young as a
professional and she doesn't do a false
take and she's you know she's I said I
think it's that professionalism you know
she just knows how to do it inside out
you know and and for someone like me
who's got
compared to her no experience is it's
you know it's very helpful now you share
a director together as well of course on
this film but before viously your first
song was warhorse directed by Steven
Spielberg and she also worked with
Steven Spielberg on were the worlds I
kind of imagine you swapping Steven
Spielberg stories on thirds yeah I mean
you know that's it's it's it's funny I
mean it's one of those you know the
whole six degrees of separation thing in
the movie industry where he does work
everyone knows everyone so it's you know
I scrape I mean you know work when you
work with Steven Spielberg it's it's a
very unique experience and and well it's
the same for direct it's really but it
but in terms of you know scale I mean
you know we have cranes for cameras and
things like for a day on a movie like
this we have seven or eight all the time
well is that like what was that like was
so it's you know the very different
types of filmmaking
you know I this movie was just as
enjoyable as doing walls because this
you get an intimacy that you don't
always get on those movies so um you
know that there's there's there's two
you know they're very different films I
guess but yeah on War Horse of course
you had to do an accent in you doctor
different accent her own and on this one
Dakota has to do that with world isn't
she she kind of does a British accent we
you you kind of relieved to be leaving
those accent duties to somebody else um
no I see I I always try and do something
else a voice wise just because it's a
great way to kind of anchor a character
or something and when you start talking
that voice you stop being that and I've
done this was the first film I did very
I remember thinking I kind of I
definitely didn't want Mike I know I
have quite a RP accent I wanted to just
tighten that down a little bit I didn't
want to be I didn't want people to go
posh for its kind of things they were so
you know it's it's a great tool only
what to get you know but obviously
Dakota is doing something very different
normally
I mean I've just come back from doing a
movie playing American and the amount of
work that goes into learning an accent
that's boring work yeah it's very dull
you're spending hours and hours and
hours going through all these drills
with a dialect coach and you know you
know it's monotonous and you have to get
it to a stage where you don't even have
to think about anymore and that's that's
that's what decoded it very well you
know there was you didn't feel like she
was doing accent because she got it to
that stage where you got set and then
you'll have to worry about as acting the
accent is so done you know either you
can you can forget about it yeah you've
worked on a number of movies now have
any obviously War Horse the first one
now is good you mentioned the other one
though you're doing American accent I
mean when you started with warhorse you
kind of talked about being terrified
when you were doing every scene almost
how do you feel now when you're on set
how is it on now is good well what
waters did was kind of I'd I never
expect I don't know why but Wars coming
out was a shock to me I'd I was
surprised that people you know got
people actually gonna see what we shot
you know and there's always the thought
in the back of your head what you do in
that next 30 seconds is gonna be around
forever and that's what's gonna be on
the screen in front of five many cinemas
and how many people can see it and it's
gonna be on the DVD and unlike theatres
there is no rehearsal on film almost I
mean this there certainly wasn't any
rehearsal and you know I I just come
from I mean not much work but if they
had a background and there were I'm used
to three months or hustle so you're
turning up on the day and you're doing
saying the words for the first time you
ever said them with the other actors and
you might be you might not even be
saying them to the other actor you might
be saying it the cameras here is three
inches of running your face and you're
talking to a Red Cross and you're
pretending that you're in love with the
Red Cross and there's a cameraman
scratching his ass you know just there
and there's a you know a hundred other
people on set and and it's very weird
you know I mean that all the interior
house scene
you know when you shoot in a studio it's
it's it's very sterile environment and
you know it's it's it's funny this I
guess that's where this the stress has
come from at the same time the shooting
schedule that you have on movies like
this especially you know the low-budget
movies is so intense that you don't have
time to get nervous and you certainly
don't have time to get worried about
coming out like I just I just don't
think about it coming out it seems to
work for me
yeah exactly yeah you pretend that
you're the only one that's yeah we
didn't like doing that scene where is it
in Brighton it's filmed we shot a lot in
Brighton we shot London London yeah a
lot of the exterior stuff was in
Brighton you have a scene that you were
you kind of you are going to go into the
sea don't you and bright and I think it
is what was it like filming that short
well you have to brace yourself to get
into the water well you know like Italy
it was 3:00 in the morning I think and
we've been shooting all night and we
said a lot more to shoot all the stuff
in the motorbike we shot as the Sun was
coming up that morning after having been
up all day and all night and the last
thing you I do really is run into the
North Sea you know you know Dakota
wasn't complaining and say I thought if
a 17 year old girl isn't complaining I
certainly can't throw her I just have to
grin and bear it I think I squealed one
okay I do keep yourself fresh when
you're having to kind of work at that
sort of schedule you know when you're
having to do three o'clock shoots and
you having to be then on a motorbike at
6:00 a.m. or something
well let's bless your job you know I
mean that about that is the job I guess
you know the really big emotional scene
that I have with Dakota on the hill when
my character to see moment my character
is you can't you know it loses his
composure and I had the worst food
poisoning during that day and you know I
was feeling terrible and you know not
you're feeling you're feeling pretty
grim but the cameras are rolling and
there's no there's no you know there's
no stopping that so you've just got a
do your best okay the movie as well is
all about living in the moment very much
isn't and taking all the opportunities
that are open to you and seizing ones
that maybe aren't there making them for
yourself I mean in your own life do you
find it easy or difficult to kind of
live in the moment rather than maybe
thinking about the future or the past
you know it's I think I mean that weirds
the thing where I'm constantly thinking
about okay right I'm gonna do this movie
and we're gonna do it like thinking how
we're gonna do it okay now we're going
on to the next movie guys so I guess no
more think about the future of the home
I guess be on your bucket list like the
one that decays house in the film you
know I don't I don't know I think you
know obviously if you think about it
seriously you'd want to be a family
wouldn't you I guess if I was in a silly
mood I did a skydive the other day that
was pretty awesome and so I died one day
loads of stupid stuff like that well
this is an adaptation isn't it now it's
good and you know strange to adaptations
with warhorse you've got another one
coming up with great expectations what
can we expect from that well gross
rotations is you know we have we haven't
had a classical movie version in 60
years so it's it's it's about time yet
another and it's it's nice to do a movie
where we didn't have to get caught up in
I think so many period movies are boring
because actors you tend to get caught up
in the etiquette and you tend to get
kind of constricted by it and two
characters saying that they love each
other across the room is often you know
done this very sort of and you're in the
period FCAT you're saying I love you
know and it's all it did I feel like we
made a conscious decision not to have
that I mean you're only got to read
Shakespeare tonight people fall just in
violently in love nowadays as they did
you know hundreds of years ago and so
we've done it in a way that I think is
raw and visceral and the emotions are
very much on the surface and when they
break out it is violent and it's no
different than if you were doing a
modern piece yeah
and as you say there have been a number
of versions for over the years although
not a classical version for a number of
years but one of the classics of course
is a David Lean one isn't it with John
Mills and the lead role what's it feels
stepping into those shoes well well that
was actually the last classical movie
adaptation and that was in 1946 I didn't
I didn't I didn't I didn't think about
it so because it's it's you know it we
had David Nicholls writing scripts and I
think he wrote as close to a thriller as
you can with this kind of movie I mean
when the book came out it was it was
cool you know people said it was a
thriller and I think we tried to get
back to that and it's a very different
movie as is everyone so you know I mean
every other patient will be different
and this isn't I haven't gone and looked
at other people I kept and go oh yeah
and I'd be nice let's do that it's just
that you know it is this all got to come
from inside you I guess it sounds
terribly pretentious third yeah and
you're closing the London Film Festival
this year with that film as well how
does that feel um I feels you know it's
it's it's a huge honor I guess I mean
the whole thing's surreal you know the
fact that it's coming out of cinema let
alone closing a Film Festival this is
weird it's a yeah and finally I just
want to ask you a little bit about some
two of the film's you've got coming
coming up a night in Old Mexico and also
the railway man you've got coming up too
haven't you
yeah yeah I mean obviously you know I've
only really just finished post those
movies a railway man here's a story that
I felt an incredible responsibility in
doing it's about a a torch victim
where's the Japanese on the death
railway during the second world war and
I spent time with the real man that I'm
playing so therefore you feel that you
feel a certain sense of responsibility
that you maybe wouldn't do normally so I
was you know things like I mean I lost a
lot of a lot of weight for that movie
and and and did thing you know things I
would normally do for a role so that's
gonna be fascinating that's what Colin
Firth and Nicole Kidman so I'll be very
very interesting how that turns out and
the other movie night Mexico which is
which is comedy and a bit lighter which
is nice and you know again to work with
a cinema legend you know
Robert Duvall and you know again it's
it's a weird and wacky script and it's
yeah it's good it's fun it's it's it's
very original and that's that's what
always draws me to movies like that only
hopes and dreams for next projects
I mean I've you know I'm always reading
scripts I've there's a there's a real
drought of good scripts at the moment I
think there's a lot of regurgitation of
stuff we've seen again and again I've
yeah and and finding a good script is
tough and when you do find and you find
that it's it's you know it's it's a
feeding frenzy you know every actor kind
of goes Oh finally it's you know
something something genuinely good and
and new and and so it's you know I
certainly say no to a lot more than I
say yes to but um you know there's some
there's some few very exciting projects
out there I'd love to go and do some
theatre in the next couple years again
but yeah we'll see this there's some
there's some really exciting stuff being
made so yeah
you